e
everyone uh it looks like um we are
short on committee members um but I am
opening the uh subcommittee work session
on HB 153
and I would just ask everyone to take a
seat up here I just I wanted this to be
a
conversation uh to discuss the best way
thank you all for being here um if we
can just go around the uh table once
everyone is settled introduce yourself
and uh that'd be great and uh uh may we
Jerry so red is on okay I'm uh Jerry
suula I'm a retired UNH Professor I have
been the instructor for the animal
cruelty courses that are current at the
New Hampshire police academy and I'm
co-chair of the governor's Commission on
the Humane treatment of
animals I'm Kurt Arenberg with the uh
humane Society of the United States I'm
also on the governor's Commission on the
Humane treatment of
animals I'm Rob Johnson the policy
director with New Hampshire Farm
Bureau Vincent greo Captain with the
state police assigned to the operations
Bureau overseeing special services which
includes Arcanine unit as well as troops
a C and
F uh good morning everyone my name is
John skip I'm the director of New
Hampshire police standards and
training great thank you thank you
everyone so I want to have a discussion
I had put in a bill this year well I've
actually put it in in a couple different
formats and um I don't know if you I'm
sure you've all seen the bill it was to
require a one sheriff or Deputy in each
County and one state trooper in each
County be trained in animal cruelty uh
specifically the laws
um we're finding
that there's a
disconnect um and local law enforcement
does not have is isn't always up on
everything and I thought a minimum of 20
people in law
enforcement would be important to have
trained so that they could be a resource
not that you would be
responsible but for contact or or maybe
possible assistance um I don't know if
that's the right approach um but I know
that something definitely needs to be
done in this state um I mean we had
someone here from law enforcement
testify and earlier in the original
testimony and when asked about did he
realize that you had a have a
veterinarian accompanying law
enforcement they didn't know that uh for
removal of
animals um so there's some things and I
would like to you know Jerry if you
don't mind I would love to have you
speak on this because I know you have
done offered courses at New Hampshire
standards and training and you are have
been immersed in this issue for a long
time so um why don't you give us your
thoughts on what you think should be
done and how we should handle this at
level first I'd like to
um give you a little bit of a background
um in
when I taught at UNH I taught in the
animal science program and uh I had
started on the governor's commission and
it became very clear that police
officers were not trained in animal
cruelty
investigations so I actually started an
online class for both UNH students and
anyone else that wanted to take it
um well back about 2005
and uh I actually had some police
officers take it uh Animal Control
Officers members of the public UNH
students didn't want it because it was
online at the time it was not the big
deal online so they didn't want it so um
I was actually contacted by New
Hampshire police standards and training
to put together a course a two-hour
course for the recruits and I
started the preliminary discussions were
in 2007
um the First Co course I taught I
believe was in 2008 at the 146th Academy
um long time ago very basic an overview
of what the issues are in New Hampshire
what they might
see the laws um
and some investigative techniques uh and
a lot of resources who's out there to
help um
the it in
2023 because of all the changes at at
the police academy had became an online
class and I put that one together I'm
assuming they're still using the same
one I don't know if they've upgraded
it in um 2009 I started I was invited to
teach a two-day in service class which
was much more
comprehensive um um and I actually
called it animal cruelty the law
investigation and case
resolution and um I taught that from
2009 to
2014 then we had some issues with the
tend having enough attendance then I
taught it in 2017 and 2019 and I haven't
taught it since then um I learned a lot
from that class from officers in the
field
the we had regular police officers
taking it they allowed Animal Control
Officers to come into the class they
even allowed a couple
Humane investigators to take the class
so um I learned a lot from that I
revised it just about every year as I
did the twoyear the two-hour one I
changed that as things changed and um
because um
involved with all of this at one point
the governor's commission had a website
with a lot of resources on animal
cruelty investigations I moved that over
to New Hampshire police standards and
training because it had a lot of police
procedure and stuff in it I didn't think
it
was appropriate for the general public
so um that is up there now under your
benchmark
program available to any certified
police officer but it's like um you can
take a horse to water but you can't make
them drink so and we have a very
comprehensive cruelty manual um
so the 2-hour course is
mandated is
it so at the um at the Academy level yes
uh so we we do uh hold the recruits to
complete that kind of an introductory
uh program and then the doctor's program
that is on Benchmark uh which is our uh
Statewide learning management system uh
is in the format of a asynchronous
online learning program so literally a
police officer on duty or off duty at 2
o'clock in the morning can sign in and
complete the class uh if they choose to
it's not mandated for inservice officers
uh inservice officers would be those off
officers that have already graduated
from the police academy and they're out
there you know working um so do you have
any way to track who actually takes
those courses absolutely we do
and how many people have actually taken
it in the last say five years I I wish I
had that answer for you I do not but I
can certainly get that answer for this
committee uh we can just run uh some
analytics and Benchmark and it'll it'll
tell us okay I would like to
it's not actually a course it's it's a
composite broken down by categories of
resources some of them
are courses that I put together my
PowerPoints that are narrated some of
them are just documents that they can
refer to so again um they it's it's not
something they sign into and take a
course but if they have if they need
information on anything related to
animal cruelty it's there and I also put
up the changes in the law because it's
the only way that they're going to be uh
aware of some of those things so then
I'm I'm speaking to the recruit block
exactly is the asynchronous block that
they can access anytime uh whether they
were at the Academy or not the recruits
they can uh the general police force uh
as well no so that you know that might
be something that we can do is just put
that block of
instruction on uh the learning
management system for everyone to look
at yeah uh because technically anybody
that went through before 2008 has not
had that so so let
me
now you just so that everyone
understands there's a 2-hour course
that's required if you as going through
the current current Academy that's just
basically an
introduction then you at one point were
teaching a two-day course it was that 16
hours is it two full days or just so
16 okay a 12-h hour course okay and now
there is information online what how
does the information online differ from
a two-day course and what would what is
what can someone get out of a two-day
online it was originally designed as
resource material for the two-day
class so um the class was designed to go
with the manual so if somebody wants to
do a self-study it's all there but it's
not guided anymore if you know if I were
to teach the course it would be guided I
actually would give them some homework
to go look at some of that stuff um and
make sure they knew how to use it and
those kinds of things so
um it's not actually a course and it
would require somebody with the
wherewithal to do some preliminary
background work to know what they could
resources okay um Kurt Rob do you have
anything that you'd like to add about
this um your thoughts on on this
training uh you know do you think it's
essential for law enforcement to be
involved in this Kurt
please
so speaking for my organization and I
think for some members of the commission
what what what our
goal immediate goal would be is to make
name I apologize for that
Interruption I appreciate that that's
okay
um so our Our concern is that if there's
an animal
in in distress because someone is acting
cruy criminal criminally Cru cruy to
this
animal that there is a police officer
trained in animal cruelty that can
respond to that case no matter where and
when in the state it takes place
so it seems that what we need is some
sort of a
protocol through law enforcement
channels that if I'm in pitfield New
Hampshire or any other
location and I call someone and saying
there's a cruelty
case that is responded to in some way as
an animal cruelty case that will be
dealt
with
accordingly and how that pertains to
training is that there should be someone
available either on a state County local
level maybe it's that's in reverse
order but to respond to that call who
understands what Jerry was just talking
about that would be our goal as soon as
possible I appreciate that uh having had
some constituent call me and complained
that they didn't feel like uh issues
were being addressed and when I got
called the state fat um they said well
we don't have jurisdiction it's local
law enforcement I called the sheriff he
goes I can't get involved um and the
police department
responded they they thought they
remedied it and
then they said okay it's being taken
care of and
um they
um to gave it back to the uh owner the
person called me again I called the
state vets office and they said well
they couldn't get someone out there for
days um you know when we're talking 100
degree weather and a horse can't get to
so that is why this bill is here because
law enforcement doesn't didn't
understand the protocol on what needed
to be done and you law enforcement is
the only one that can go in and serve a
warrant or really do investigation
unless you have an animal control
officer I guess on in your town a lot of
towns in New Hampshire do not have
acos so I know in my town personally
they deal with the uh local
sbca um you know if they confiscate
animals or whatever
but I really think that there is a lack
of knowledge of the laws and I don't
think it's something that PE when you go
into law enforcement that you think this
is going to be like oh gee this is you
know that's not what they're going to
law enforcement for but animal cruelty
in is is a big deal in this state when
it happens we need people that
understand the laws and can react
quickly
um so uh uh ma'am uh please turn on your
mic and introduce yourself and where
you're
from hi I'm Mary Rose De I'm from
conquered New
Hampshire and I'm just don't have any
feelings one way or the other about the
bill I just um the only thing I would
worry about with this law is there are
people who bring their pets to these
grocery
stores and they are uh emotional support
animals and under the law now they can
be fined
$1,200 because uh they spread parasites
to the food and stuff that like uh blood
worms and stuff like that to people's
food so that would I would not consider
if you ask the person to take their dog
and leave the store a grocery store or
something like that I wouldn't consider
that to be animal cruelty no so
um thank you for that ma'am this this
bill is about getting training this has
nothing to do with enforcement this is
about training law enforcement
specifically so that they do understand
the
law okay um Rob would you like to chime
in
please this this was a an idea as the
the chair knows they came up and was
discussed at our County our uh State
annual meeting where our we have
delegates from each of the we're we're
an organization of 10 County F beer
organizations and our that we have
delegates to to our annual meeting and
and this is a a discussion that we had
that the thought being that similar to
again as the chair said that there would
be uh law enforcement officials widely
dispersed throughout the state that had
a a more in-depth knowledge of the
animal cruelty statutes that basically
other law enforcement could rely on to
when they came up and and the issue is
certainly the the uh uh prop dealing
with issues arising from the the care of
animals but also in particular the due
process for the owners themselves that
all that's kind of where where we were
uh uh coming with and and we
understanding that as as uh law
enforcement officials I mean you've got
an awful lot on your plate and that
probably not every every office or even
every agency especially in a smaller
Department of the state would have the
time to take a you know a course and to
be up to date so I thinking was being if
the you Kurt mentioned Pittsfield that
if they didn't have an officer on on in
the department or on duty that that felt
comfortable with that they had somebody
they could call on who was a like-minded
you know person that you know kind of
walk them through okay this is what you
need to be doing be looking out for and
be a resource to them that that's kind
of what we were we were coming from and
I did have one question for the director
um I'm a I'm a graduate of police St is
way back 106 class so I'm I'm curious
you said is it R all online because the
way I understood
the no it's uh um it is a 16 week uh
brick and mortar uh just like you went
through still okay yeah uh the
unfortunate truth is that the length of
the
academy uh has not changed over the last
uh bunch of years and yet uh there has
been a significant amount of pressure
pressure to add extra things to the
academy and so uh we found that uh there
are certain times and I'm sure you can
remember like when you were waiting to
get on the Range uh you you would sit
outside the range and you'd be filling
your magazines or or speed loaders maybe
back in those days I don't know whe you
had a wheel gun or semi-automatic but uh
same thing with scenario training
driving uh we you can't put 30 people in
police police cars and have them drive
all at the same time so they have to
wait their turn and so we saw that
time uh you know let's let's leverage
this time and and make it of some value
some training value uh and at the same
time we could take some of the
programming and put that into a online
program so that the recruits could uh
asynchronously jump in there while they
were waiting to go to a another block of
instruction and get through that train
as well so so so they're doing that
while they're at the Academy that is
correct yeah but candidly they can they
can be home at two o'clock in the
morning and and use our system to get to
that training and complete it on their
own so thank you yes would you like to
chime in you in the field and this would
affect your troops so
um I appreciate you having me here I was
not here for um the original testimony
of the biller for the last work group I
believe but I do appreciate being able
to sit here today uh I know that Captain
amuchi already spoke on some of this so
if there's something that I've missed or
something that I can add obviously
um our view on this is that obviously
we're looking to be compatible with our
local partners and with you to to
accomplish whatever it is U that is laid
out in front of us from from what I hear
and if it's been spoken to uh prior to
then I apologize but from what I hear
here it's looking for that realistic
realtime response that when there's an
investigation or an allegation made that
somebody from law enforcement can
respond and while I think that notion is
is commendable and and something that we
all hope to achieve I don't know that if
ass signing one Trooper Per County or
one sheriff is realistically going to
accomplish that the reason that I say
that is for for a number of reasons um
one it's a 247 job when these calls come
in and one Trooper in one County
covering you know a vast area isn't
going to be that one Trooper that's
going to be trained that can respond to
to a call for service in that real time
manner it may be that a a trooper on
patrol response gathers the information
and then goes back and has to refer to
somebody on what are my next steps or
what exactly do I have going on and that
may be a phone
call that company by the fact that often
times especially given our vacancy rates
right now which are approaching 20%
vacancy rates to then task one Trooper
Per County with the responsibility of
all animal cool investigations that come
in um while I wouldn't say is unfair I
just I don't know if I can sit here and
say that that's a realistic possibility
that somebody could immediately respond
in a state police capacity in that very
moment from what I understand and from
what this group is I do lend more
towards the fact that and from things
that I've heard from Members today is it
it's not just that the person responding
has intimate knowledge of what needs to
take place for the investigation but
more so that they know where to go to
get the information of how to proceed so
I don't know if that um falls directly
on a local agency or a sheriff's
department or the state police certainly
we're we're willing to help and we're
we're always willing to help with
whatever the investigations are as we
would with any other type of criminal
investigation throughout the state but
uh the notion that one Trooper in one
County would be able to handle be that
one that one voice for anybody that had
an issue I don't know if that would hit
the mark of of really what the root of
what it is that we're trying to achieve
which I think is as great as a as a
12year can9 Handler myself and someone
who's been involved in animal felty
investigations somebody who's um charged
persons for assaults on my own canine
Partners uh I I'm I'm rooted in this and
I I believe in in in what we're trying
to achieve here I I I would agree that I
think there just may be other ways to go
about it but but certainly we're willing
to be involved in whatever capacity is
decided okay I I just oh oh
representative Freeman please thank you
and um I I want to apologize to the
committee for um being late um I did
want to ask you a question sir over the
years that you've had reported animal
cruelty cases or suspected animal
cruelty cases how has your department
handled it thus far again I'm coming in
late to the conversation so I I
apologize if it's if this question is
redundant how how typically are you
handling it right now so I can speak to
ones that I'm aware of I can't speak to
all cases throughout throughout the
state that State Police has been a
primary on or maybe a secondary or just
a phone call um I had the opportunity
throughout my career this being my 20th
year uh in in this state and in another
to be involved in in situations like
this I'll speak specifically to New
Hampshire most recently uh I was
assigned as the commander of Troop C
which is our westernmost troop based out
of Keane which is a rural troop 38
communities State Police is primary for
almost 20 Towns now in that area
providing law all law enforcement
Services the experiences that I had were
were very positive in handling those
cases again specific to M what I can say
is in the initial response from State
Police the foundation of a criminal
investigation
for the most part is is very very
similar in nature gathering information
looking up uh rsas to see what the
Baseline is of what's what's a violation
uh what crosses it into a misdemeanor or
a felony so on and so
forth where it was nice in my experience
moving beyond is you spoke to the Animal
Control Officers in the in certain towns
we didn't have a lot of Animal Control
Officers in any of the towns around us
but the ones that we did have were more
than willing to lend a hand come up to
whatever scene we were at and at least
give an advice and assistance so that we
knew what the next step would be and I
found that to be the same with any of
the animal groups in ASPCA and our state
vet uh to include local veterinarians
who are willing to give their expertise
and help out so my experience was um
knowing that we had an issue and we may
not necessarily um be deeply trained in
one specific area but that could also be
be true for a lot of different areas
where we receed tring at the Academy and
then it's up to the agency or it's up to
the The Troop Commander or it's up to
the ship supervisor or the officer
themselves the trooping themselves to
further their own education knowing what
they're going to come across in their
specific control areas so my experience
was very positive and that I had those
resources albe it it may not be into
I'll say pitsfield only because it was
brought up earlier I don't want to
include or exclude any specific town but
uh Pittsfield in a silo I don't know
whether it's true or not I don't know if
they have an animal control officer but
if I was the trooper that was in that
town I would I'd feel very comfortable
knowing that I could pick up the phone
call a multitude of resources and get
that
information the power was in knowing
that I had access to the information not
that I necessarily had specific training
in everything that I was going to come I
should say specialized training in every
specific thing that I was going to come
up upon I have no doubt that there are
instances where there are local officers
sheriffs State Troopers that respond to
a call uh regarding animal cruelty and
it's probably the first time that
they've had to respond to something like
that and they're unaware of what their
next step is the next step can't be well
I tried my best and I turned and I I
left that that's unacceptable on all
fronts but a lot of it is knowing where
do I go to find that information what
resources do I have available thank you
following up on what uh representative
Freeman just said how do we get that
information out there and into the hands
of law enforcement that isn't aware I
mean for instance how did you know where
to go and how did you find the
information that you
needed again for me specifically there
was a little bit of an awareness having
to have researched some of the state
laws because of my involvement in the K9
unit um however though I had incidences
before I was involved in the can9 unit
and a lot of that was just self-growth
self-education of things that I knew I
was going to come across within my
specific Patrol area you may have a a a
primarily Highway troop if you will an
interstate troop it doesn't necessarily
go into the county often or agencies
within that County are large full-time
PDS that are uh seemingly adequate to
handle things like that assigning a
trooper one per County signing a trooper
in that area may not be as useful as if
there were more people trained in the
western part of the state or the
northern part of the state which again
would bring me back to the idea
of
um the Troopers knowing that there's
resources available to them that they
can reach out to so no matter where they
are or what time of the day it is it's
just a phone call away to
them and in furtherance of answering
that your question um the block of
instruction that the recruits receive is
really uh it is more
awareness and more these are the
resources that you would turn to uh for
help if you come into one of these cases
so uh it is to be candid it is not a
robust it's not like the two-day class
that the doctor uh uh used to teach uh
on how to conduct the investigations it
is much more an awareness class and a uh
identification of experts uh and and uh
you know resources that the officer can
turn to uh to further an
investigation the original in intent of
the bill was not to have the sheriff's
department and State Police be the
primary person to go in and be
responsible for these but to be a
resource or
assist um local law enforcement um but
like you said in in 20 towns you are the
primary source of law
enforcement
so you know I
think I'm not sure which way to go and I
I'd like to hear everyone's thoughts I
don't know if two hours is enough
training I don't know um you
know how we handle this but this is a
real issue in the state of New Hampshire
that we need to address um because you
know
there are cases that get pushed down the
road you know uh yeah it's a problem but
we're not going to deal with it so then
it goes this way or there's some issues
where it's handled very wrongly and it
has devastating effects um the opposite
way because they're too aggressive um
and not understanding the laws I mean we
have some changes coming up to uh that
the other thing that we had changed uh
put into legislation through this
committee as a cost of care because uh
towns were afraid to look at animal
cruelty because of the cost that it
would do therefore we created a cost of
care fund at the state level to assist
so that people would not be afraid of
the cost to the taxpayer for for dealing
with these
situations so I am open to suggestions
on how we handle this but this is
something that really needs to be dealt
with and we keep kicking this can down
the road and I don't
know the right
answer but I'm hoping that with everyone
here that's been involved that's in
training that has taught classes that's
in been involved in animal cruelty cases
uh where it's worked well where it
hasn't what is I would love to come up
with a solution that's best for everyone
that also protects you know does what
we're trying to do real time enforcement
with the understanding you know of the
law uh when an animal can be taken when
it cannot be taken things like that
because sometimes the animal doesn't
need to be taken but it's an education
piece sometimes it's not and you need to
enforce
things so um
um hi this is Mary Rose De again um well
even though um you mentioned the western
part of the state um there's a growing
problem with the homeless population in
the urban areas lots of them have
dogs and um they go out in this weather
that's extremely cold the dog's paws are
not covered with any kind of shoes the
dogs are um emaciated because they
have oh okay the dogs are suffering from
the cold in the winter and uh they can't
go to a shelter with the dogs so um
there's this Urban problem of what do
you do take the dogs U do you have to do
homeless um interventions with the
person that owns the dog um but I have
given like $20 to somebody that had a
dog a few years ago that it was like
around 0 degre out and the dog's Paws
were right on the ice and I said here's
$20 I don't know if you can get your dog
some dog
slippers um but I was really concerned
the dog was very
skinny and so I don't know if they were
it wasn't deliberate cruelty but it was
the animal was really
suffering kind of a so M mixed social
issue and uh uh economic issue but also
the dog was in immediate
danger of dying but then on the other
hand you have this issue with people in
their pets and the grocery stores that
the pets do have parasites and the
governor has already P passed some
legislation that these people they're
not service animals if they're emotional
support pets and as such can't go with
the owner to the grocery store um it's
only for service animals that I I guess
they have to be licensed by the health
and human services department so I would
excluding that piece I would say that
the rest I don't know I have don't I
know how the law is defined as far as
animal cruelty but like endangering the
life of an animal um attacking an
animal would be how I would Define it it
is defined in statute under RSA 644 okay
all right represent Freeman and then
Jerry thank you representative comot so
um what I think I'm hearing a lot of
what are saying is that we need to work
up a protocol on how to handle these
complaints so I'm just going to make a a
real quick suggestion um I know Leos
have their protocols anytime a call
comes in there's a certain there's a
certain rubric you follow um in order to
address whatever the complaint is
investigate Etc so I think maybe if we
work up a protocol um that would include
the Humane Society because they're so
heavily involved with this um that they
could assist the Leos in these types of
investigation so it doesn't fall all in
the Leos to make a determination about
whether there is a valid complaint about
animal cruelty and um you know one of
the things I am hearing Leo say is they
don't know every law that's on the books
they can't know every law that's on the
books they they're intelligent enough to
research those laws but it's technically
it's not their job to know all the laws
so I think if if if we sat down and
looked at working up um a protocol where
it would satisfy the need of having that
extra layer of protection for those
complaints that are filed but also
doesn't pull Leos in seven different
directions um I'm that that's just my
suggestion because again most things
that especially with law enforcement
there is a protocol and protocols work
because you follow that protocol so um
and there's no there's there's no
there's really very small margin for
error when it comes to protocols um
I would just interject on one thing and
that is I would think
that I don't think there is that
many well I shouldn't say this how many
animal cruelty laws do we have per year
in the state how many how how many
complaints do we have you know that of
true animal cruelty true animal cruelty
not um you know there's some people that
think that a cow because their bones are
sticking out is animal cruelty but
that's just the way the cow looks and
versus livestock so I'm
just you understand what I'm saying
something if there is a
complaint comes into any Leo it needs to
be
investigated and if the officer is
trained they're going to know whether
there's Merit or not to start with and
that's what this is all
about this is the manual that is on our
website the governor's commission
website it's on the resources website
it's on the Attorney General's website
it's everything is here okay and that's
that's the information that they were
saying that they could go on and and
search there's a lot more online okay
all the nitty-gritty that's not in here
with how to investigate how to do um
body condition scoring on lots of
different species and the difference
between livestock and companion animals
and all of that it's all available now
you asked about possible
solutions and I don't know how um how to
go about this but if there was a way
that we could get a voluntary group both
in maybe the southern part of the state
or the northern part of the state that
would get additional training and now
one of the other issues I had with the
bill as you've written it
6448 is um just the animal cruelty law
your law did not take into account
animal fighting and beastiality which
are separate laws and those require a
lot of specific training if you get
involved with any one of those cases
which would involve the forensics lab
and things like that as well so um
there's a lot more to this but if you
could get a voluntary group that would
and there are I know there are ACO uh
acos and police officers out there that
have a passion about cruelty to animals
they would sign up and they could be a
resource either just for advice or this
is what you need to do or this is the
information you need or if they had time
and some of them will do it on their own
time to go out and help with an
investigation and this would
include um acos many of whom do not have
any law enforcement
Authority
veterinarians we need to get some
livestock large animal veterinarians on
board this would include police officers
perhaps state police officers I I think
almost any can9 Handler would love to
would be amenable to being on this
resource um and
prosecutors right and I know that there
are some people in the sheriff's
department that you know also are you
know have are passionate about the
animals um you know we've had uh we
always have someone on the governor's
commission so um
so setting up a task force in the
southern I know you're talking voluntary
but if we do voluntary how long will
that take to do H if we did a task force
and I'm going to look at you over there
to answer that what would that look like
and what kind of resources would that
pull so thank you for that question and
and
um there there are the doctor's correct
there's a there's a number of police
officers across the state that uh have
uh a passion for this and candidly
uh I'll I'll share I'm an AGR brother
from UNH and uh a couple of my uh
fraternity brothers are police officers
and they they graduated with degrees in
in uh uh you know from T school and and
uh you know four four-year uh so uh the
there there are pops out in in the state
of New Hampshire that have deep subject
matter expertise in these areas probably
not many right uh the there's a there's
a couple of different ways that this
could be you know
addressed uh I don't know that a
volunteer program is going to work in
this day and age uh it it it just it
will not work uh notwithstanding
people's passion uh these are uh
legitimate criminal investigations that
would need to have the full backing
authority of the agencies that are going
to be digging into them uh couple of
different models can be looked at uh the
first model would be that local agencies
identify uh people within their agency
that are both willing and have the
training to be called upon as a resource
uh a great example is uh presently the
state of New Hampshire keeps a list of
available drug recognition experts
Dres uh and those Dres are made
available uh by the hiring authority to
respond to help with a a uh impaired
driver crash or or an impaired driver
arrest but somebody has to write the
check for that who's going to pay the
officer to uh to go and assist that Dr
has to be compensated for their their um
investigative efforts that would be one
way to do it is is to create a list
of uh not drug recognition experts but
create a list of animal cruelty
investigators uh that could be made
available throughout the
state I think the big piece there uh
would be twofold one training and and we
can do the training I I just need some
money to hire uh people like Dr Z or or
you know the folks that that are
represented here to build out that
curriculum and it's going to be a big
curriculum right you got to talk about
every animal specifically there's going
to be some you know specifics to that
and then this the second piece to the
list of animal cruelty investigators
would be who is going to compensate them
is does the home agency compensate them
does the requesting agency compensate
them does the state compensate them that
would be one way to do it an alternative
way to do it would be to create
a task
force uh there are task forces that are
created throughout the state and what
happens is a a police agency will take
somebody who's very good at this
particular thing and will use drug
investigations as an example and uh they
go to specialized training and and a lot
of it quite frankly and then that home
agency gives up the officer for a period
of time they might serve six months they
might serve a year
and their full-time job is just doing
the task
force again and uh the captain spoke of
this uh we see we are seeing shortages
of police officers across the state of
New Hampshire and and generally one of
the first places that a police chief or
uh the colonel of State Police will look
to to get their their roles kind of back
up would be to pull those task off uh
Task Force officers back to the road and
back to the home AG
gency a third option might be to create
uh a couple of few positions within the
Department of Agriculture at the state
level and and I'll I'll give you an
example and uh look at the Fire
Marshal's Office the Fire Marshal's
Office is responsible for investigating
cases of
arson uh there is nobody else in the
state of New Hampshire that that
oversees those
investigations uh arson is a very very
specific crime that takes not only law
enforcement experience but firefighting
experience and you have to put those two
things together and there's very few
people that have a foot on either side
of that fence right and that's why the
Fire Marshal's Office exists to do those
very specific
investigations uh you could maybe mirror
that under the Department of Agriculture
and have you know two or four
officers assigned specifically to
address the the very crimes that uh the
doctor just outline not only animal
cruelty but any crime that involves
either a domestic animal or a farm
animal so I think those are three ways
that you could kind of skin this cat uh
but again you know in this day and age
it it really is about the money and and
how does that get funded and how does
that get sustained over a period of time
okay um so just a one I don't think the
task force is really the way to go
because I don't think we need someone
dedicated for six you know we're pulling
someone from law enforcement for six
months I just don't see that as as as
viable um however I did like your first
option um because it's really we want to
have people that are trained and we want
there to be resources it's all about the
the resources right and understanding
the law and you know whether it's local
law enforcement that responds but can
draw on that expertise or it it's
someone from the actual uh that's in
that group that
responds um you know and as you said you
know you might have some acos but acos
don't not all acos you know can go in
and deal with this uh and it could be
veterinarians but veterinarians don't
have that component
so I really liked your first option and
um I don't know ballpark wise how much
training would cost and what you know
and how many people would volunteer to
sign up for that so I guess that's one
component of it but the other thing I'm
thinking about
and I know I'm probably going to uh I'm
going to just say it but the cost of
care fund is all about
compensating the municipality for cost
of care um and part of that I would
think we could include
is the actual legal part of that because
that all becomes I mean I it it seems to
be tied together um and you know maybe
we need to change some of the language
about that um but that that's just a
thought um so I'd like to hear from Rob
about what your thoughts are because
yeah I I'd agree of the options that the
director mentioned I mean that's kind of
the what
our least our thought was behind the
bill um the the cost of care fund is I
think you know that would I don't know
is we have um I think the department
would have some concerns with that I
but hey we're all just talking here
right we're just trying to figure things
out right I mean obviously if when we're
dealing with dollars right dollars and
cents um and uh in in this ye budget
year um you know Kurt
please just one point I want to make
clear is that there's a lot of talk
about resources which is terrific but
the response for the
animal is a is a concern that needs to
be addressed that when we have an animal
in distress because of Cruelty of from a
human um that that animal deserves a
response that
will if if deserving put put that animal
right into a a care situation which is
covered by the cost of care fund
notwithstanding any comments about the
cost of care fund otherwise at this
point but I mean I do think the respon
resp is is as
important certainly for the animal at
the time which is my concern here that
that animal get police response
immediately no matter where in the state
so that's kind of
the the
inequality if you're in a if you're in a
community that is served well by an
animal control officer or more than one
like I think of nasua or other cities in
this state um then you're you're you're
as an animal you're you're at a great
Advantage but if you live in a town or
location that does not have those
resources in terms of
response then you could be left to even
die in that situation so that's that's
where I just want to see some kind of
protocol as the representative was
saying in place as soon as possible so
those animal are taken care of right and
and that's why I think the first option
would work best because you're going to
get people that are invested in care
about animals um you're not asking you
know just every law enforcement officer
do you're asking people that have a
passion um for animals um and I and I
think when you have a passion for
something it makes a huge
difference um Jerry did you have
something yes um I wanted to to um speak
about possible training type things
there are some excellent training
National training programs that are
accredited that um in addition it's not
necessary that you would need to hire
someone to teach at the Academy either
myself or anyone else but there are um
great programs the University of uh
Missouri has the um animal cont animal
cruelty investigator course some of it's
a hybrid some of it's in person some of
it's
online um code three
Associates um there is a lot of online
resource material and the Justice
clearing house there's a lot of
resources out there that could be tapped
into and um there are depending on how
many people you needed to train um it's
possible that we could get some grants
for that through h s us uh ASPCA animal
legal defense fund so that we can
perhaps um Spread spread the costs out
somewhat so uh it might be that
you create a list of appropriate
programs for training and and and and we
find some resources for that yeah and I
agree uh it would just uh that would
necessitate that this bill be amended
yeah because as it's written now it it
clearly puts uh the uh impetus on police
standers and training to develop and
deliver the program and and I agree with
you that you know it why reinvent the
wheel if there are uh very esoteric very
specific uh types of trainings that
people uh could use and it's already
been built uh in those particular cases
uh why wouldn't we leverage that right
and and use those but but here again um
there is a cost involved to engage uh
those programs uh to send New Hampshire
officers to if if it is uh the first one
you spoke to is University of Missouri
yep yeah so does the officer have to be
on site in Missouri to attend the
program and obviously there's travel
costs there's uh back costs um they will
come to you
uh they're actually having an online
Zoom for part of it in
March it's uh
$450 for one officer yeah if you have
three plus it's 50% off yeah might be
able to get grants for that yeah that's
the kind of thing yeah the point I'm
making though is that it costs there's
going to be there's going to be cost
involved right so however those costs uh
could be handled uh I think would go a
long way in moving this initiative
forward we just can't lose sight of and
and I I'm speaking from experience here
because uh a couple of few years ago uh
police s and training was asked to do a
bunch of extra
training and uh we didn't get any
resources to help you know move that
along and we suffered from it we had to
uh you know really move a lot of other
things around so I just want to make
sure that everybody kind of keeps that
in mind okay so just based on what you
said I could you could probably Train
officers
uh the two two day one no on the
Missouri one for for cuz you said it was
half 225 per officer is that
correct no if you three or more is 50%
off it it would be so if you had a 100
that's three or
more no it is so um you know I'm just
going big right absolutely if you know
you're going to talk numbers right so
you're talking like 25 you know less
than
$25,000 they'll also come to you so you
could so um you know that's a that's not
to me that's not a lot of
dollars
um please question John when you are not
if there was something you were told you
had to include a new
curriculum and it's an unfunded mandate
so that's what you're talking about that
that's happened to
you do you ever get a request that is
funded and how does that work how do if
you were told to add on
training does it ever get is there ever
a mechanism for funding there that we
could
replicate yeah so it uh just discussions
like this sometimes uh a bill is is put
in play and and then there's some
funding attached to it to help support
it uh un the term unfunded mandate is
more kind of a a the state causing a
municipality to have to do something
right uh if the state tells me concept
of if the state tells me to do something
job do it yeah uh but
um I think the other thing to keep in
mind too and and uh the doctor uh talked
about it very early on is you can uh you
can lead the horse to the water and you
can give him a cup or a straw or a
bucket or uh but you still can't make
him drink and and again I I just think
the reality of uh staffing issues right
now uh we cannot uh we have to keep that
as part of this conversation and I would
love to I I'll call the University of
Missouri when I get back to the office
and find out what it takes to get them
to to come out here and and deliver that
block of
instruction
uh but I can't guarantee you that
anybody's going to attend yeah well well
I guess I guess the thing is
is um so we don't want to really create
a task force because we don't want to
have a dedicated law enforcement
officer you know to that because because
of Staffing and other
issues and hate to mandate volunteers
but um
maybe know um we're close to volunteers
elected um but how do
we get say
50 passionate people in the
state
that right law enforcement to under to
take this course and be part of a group
as a resource they're not act you know
they would be the resource because
that's what we're looking for right so
that at the county level at the local
level we have a case going
on you know it could be local law
enforcement that wants to be part of
this training it doesn't have to be the
state police or the
county but I'm just thinking if we get a
volunteer
group because that's we need the
resources so that local law enforcement
understands so when they get the call
they can go in and take
action and understand what they're
looking for or how to how to handle it
um Rob I'm just thinking here I want to
ask Jerry the Missouri course yeah how
do they intertwine New Hampshire law
local law that's what I I guess for
that's one of the things that I thought
about and I would say that and that's
the issue that I've one of the things
that I also did um when I was teaching
at UNH was I was one of the founders and
um uh coordinator for the New England
Animal Control Humane Academy now that
was for Animal Control Officers and
people that worked in Humane Society so
it wasn't all animal cruelty it was a
lot of animal handling and that kind of
stuff um but
that was the issue that I had when I
would have speakers come in talking
about animal cruelty the laws are so
different and people would leave those
classes thinking they could do things
that they can't do because our laws are
so different so I would say that
anything that we would do would have to
incorporate that two-hour class which
goes over New Hampshire law and that may
need to be modified but um it has to
apply to new hampsh
the most successful Workshop that I had
when I was coordinating the New England
Animal Control Humane Academy was I
wanted to
get an equin veterinarian in to discuss
animal cruelty and ecoin and I got it
approved for veterinary
CE but I got an excellent speaker but I
gave him New Hampshire laws and I said
anything you discuss has to fit New
Hampshire laws and he did that we had
veterinarians there as well as
acos um we didn't have any police
officers but um that's just the way but
that's New Hampshire law is is unique
and
confusing to say the least so aside from
statute and law what does the Missouri
course do what does it teach um it uh
cover
it the other thing is and as you
mentioned police officers are trained in
all of this but they need to know how to
apply it to animals so they're taking
the stuff that the police officers
already know and applying it to animals
so that it makes more sense now they
have different
levels and um they have level
one which is uh professional animal
cruelty investigator level two is
Advanced and uh level three is
expert and they get into some of the
specializations because um the the level
one
is animal law constitutional law
nutrition photography Communications all
stuff you've had but then when we get
into advanced um they talk about body
condition
scoring um crime scene investigations
with animal things in mind it's amazing
what you're doing with DNA now and
animal cruelty investigations which you
know you
can't it's talked about but it's not the
procedures for taking DNA samples and
where to send them and all of that stuff
um it talks about equin agricultural
animals and confinement operations and
so I'm hesitant when I hear body
conditioning I mean I've raised
livestock my whole life I know and I
find it tough when somebody asks me the
weight of my cattle and all and you make
you guess and then you put them on the
scale and you're like wow these These
are these
are scientific scores that are taught by
agricultural experts to determine
whether it's normal for that species or
not what we often hear about you know
the the livestock is entirely different
and even within livestock beef is
different from dairy and so on but it
goes over all of that and they have the
they have the experts that cover it now
I have some of those resources up on our
website but somebody that doesn't know
what they're doing is still going to be
confused by the
resources right I I I think so one of
the things that in our law it says that
if you're going to remove an animal you
have to have a licensed
veterinarian with you it's live for
livestock correct um so and speaking of
and I understand what Rob is saying
about body conditioning I had a horse I
I had a couple of drafts one all he did
was look at food and put on weight the
other one we
did all special food we separated them
we fed him more than any other animal
and he still looked this you know his
body conditioning was people would look
at him and say you know he's not healthy
and it's like he eats three times as
much as the other one who just looks at
the food um so um there's that aspect
also but if it's a proper investigation
they're going to ask for your
documentation that's the end of that
you've been taking care of your animal
so right and and and but but the
veterinarians portion I think is is key
for for law enforcement because we're
not going to expect law enforcement to
understand all of that and I think in
because of our law um and maybe do we
need to leave it at just livestock that
a veterinarian companies or is question
well um even with the livestock if a
police officer goes out they can still
do or or Humane agent goes out they can
do the preliminary
investigation and in in many cases it's
solved right there you know they go to
your house you got a skinny horse and
they see the documentation by see you
you're fine it's only when there's
probable cause that those people are not
taking care of the animals that they're
going to go
back with a veterinarian who says yes I
agree with you you have probable cause
they still have to go back and get a
warrant they can't just take it because
the veterinarian says so there's a
procedure to all of that and if you've
never done it before or have not looked
at the law since you took the academy
course to 20 years ago um it's not going
to be fresh in your mind at
all and I agree with you um on that I
just wanted to bring up that issue so
that people can understand and you know
as I explained earlier the thing I had
with the horse is getting a veterinarian
out and that's the other piece um on
some of it is making sure we have
veterinarians that are willing to go out
with law enforcement um um when they
need
them um because I you know I had one
where it's like yeah I can't get there
for 10 days I'm like well 10 days that's
not good enough you know the horses need
water um
so I don't know how to address that but
I would love for this group um this is
an early Bill we either have to amend it
and get it done by March
6th or we're going to have to wait and I
know that we don't really want to wait
on this and I am open to any and all
amendments that people would deem
necessary for
this um you
know so I'm just going to leave it there
and
something well I was just wondering if
uh there was an idea to try
to write something
up on one of these suggestions that we
could maybe agree to expore it or have
another meeting to to to agree on
some
uh one of these proposals to move
forward on or something like that but
unless it's your bill oh oh no uh I am
we're having this subcommittee and
everyone is here so we can come up with
something that works that is right I I'd
rather get something I don't want to
keep coming back I mean I brought
something last term it didn't
fly to me like the first model of uh
trying to bring together
resources I mean you probably should
restate it John what you the first
proposal there before you said the T TK
Force right the training model with uh
that you would need compensation uh for
officers going out or however they
responded so yes
that uh I I wonder if and I know this
isn't helpful
TimeWise
uh
to would a bill that establishes a a
study committee to to look at this and
uh uh you know really bring I think it
would be important to bring
representatives from the New Hampshire
Chiefs
Association uh representatives from the
New Hampshire Sheriff's
Association uh uh folks from the the uh
Veterinary uh uh Community uh and
prosecutors quite frankly I think uh the
prosecutors really hold a pretty judges
uh yeah uh you know that I I wonder if
that would be uh something that in the
long run would would help
get uh get done what we're trying to get
done I think that that would proba I
know it's not accomplishing what people
want done as quickly as possible but I
think if we want to do this right I
think that it would be the way to go um
and you know I I think um that we will I
think having it as a retaining the bill
and having it as not necessarily A study
committee but retaining the
bill um we can continue to work in this
format where if we create a study
committee it's going to be so many
people and I'd rather have the
representatives on the environment and
agriculture be the ones really looking
at this and working with all of you and
the other people that should be in
included uh so I think retaining this
bill and doing work sessions like this
um as opposed to creating an actual
study committee might may be um the way
to go but either way I think it needs I
think we can come up with
something uh good for the state that
works for everybody um and I'd rather
take a little bit more time to get it
right um I may please thank you madam
chair um so when people hear the word
study committee they automatically think
that the bill is DOA and that's not the
case here because the there is a valid
need for this but there's so many
stakeholders in this that we have to
address everyone's concern so I think a
study committee is completely
appropriate and with that um Madame
chair and members of this group I must
leave because I have to take my shelter
dog to the vet so thank you for having
me
late thank you happy Valentine's Day
repres
representative um so thoughts from
everybody else um on re either retaining
this bill or uh putting it into a study
committee so that all the stakeholders
can be involved and we can all together
craft a piece of legislation that
works um love to hear thoughts I I would
only ask that if if the bill were to uh
kind of still stay in play and I refer
to you madam on this I I don't know I
don't understand this side of the house
so much I'm just a cop but uh I would
just ask that an amendment be made that
uh uh in line uh six uh that basically
says uh uh through instruction in a
course uh uh approved by the New
Hampshire police standards and training
Council
and I think that uh just that simple
Amendment uh would help open the door to
to bring in those uh programs that are
already there that that Dr Z has has
kind of identified so okay and I had
brought forth another amendment to
include um all of the other rsas the
beastiality and everything else uh that
you had discussed um earlier um
obviously it never got introduced
because we're actually having this
so um anybody else want to chime in have
thoughts please uh I think it's better
to hold off I I think it needs more
collaboration before we can actually
have something that's going to
sustain
Rob just the the I guess the one
advantage over a
study versus retaining is with a study
you can actually get the wording down
exactly what we're looking at you know
the duties of what we've talked about as
opposed to what's what everybody sees
here we go either way I'm just just
making that point that a study you could
drill down to exactly what we're what is
going to be looked
at okay um I will discuss that with
folks to see which way they'd prefer to
go
Kurt just to be clear are you talking
about amending the bill to
have the bill then uh create a study
committee or just put the bill into
interim study so there's two things we
can do we can amend the bill to make it
to create a study committee or we can
put it into
intrum so yeah I think it'd be probably
be better to actually amend the bill and
then you spell out what you want that
study committee to highight it's
comprised and you actually create the
study Committee in the bill rather than
all right well let let's talk about that
okay yeah it would be retained correct
if you were you wouldn't be inum because
it's not it would be retained correct
that that is the correct word okay so I
want to go around the table what do you
want to see in the study committee what
what and I'll start with you
John
uh I'm still looking at the menu can you
go to somebody
else well I mean if I'm going to do this
and we're going to create this study
say so uh uh specifically Madam chair
are you asking what the uh the charge of
the commit of the study committee would
be I'm asking what your thoughts are on
what the charge of the study committee
should be what you needed to
say from your point of
[Music]
view so I I I would just I would say
that uh the the charge of the committee
would be to uh you know in investigate
and
identify uh a uh
sustainable
uh Statewide resource to assist with the
investigation of animal cruelty
investigations uh and from from my own
perspective uh representing New
Hampshire police standers and training I
I would uh just ask that uh any training
uh that uh ultimately is identified uh
as necessary to move this forward
uh that the language would say that uh a
a block of training that is approved by
the New Hampshire police sers and
training Council and then I would just I
would just want to make sure that there
would be uh some kind of uh funding
source whether that came from
um you know from the state or whether
there was grants involved but we would
just need to have a secure funding
source to to uh offset the costs of that
training and it could
be uh something as easy as a
reimbursement right so if there was a
fund that allowed police standards and
training and we do this all the time
statutorily we we have the authority to
do this where we would re reimburse the
home agency uh for costs associated with
that person attending the
training um you know right now we do
that with uh Crisis Intervention
training so any any agency that sends
one of their officers to a a weeklong
CIT training we cover the cost of the
training we cover uh any travel expense
you know we we take care of all of that
to support getting as many uh police
officers as possible trained in crisis
center vention so okay thank you and
studied other than a seat at the table
at the moment I don't have a whole lot
to add again it I I appreciate you
allowing me to to sit through it today
this is has been enlightening um I
certainly have
uh thoughts on you know on the topic uh
from from law enforcement perspective
not personally but just from what can
enforcement officer realistically manage
and handle and investigate um by him or
herself while out of the scene I think
it's appropriate that a lot of other
stakeholders are brought to the table to
see where they can weigh in and see
where that burden lies um of sharing
that investigative responsibility of
when somebody uh for lack of better
words kind of gets tagged into that
investigation um I think there needs to
be uh maybe some more discussion
in in that aspect of it so I se the
Rob effect of
microphone thank you something to the
effect of the the best way to provide
training uh to law enforcement and and
and and make them aware of resources
available um regarding animal cruelty
investigations something that okay um
anything specific that uh would the Farm
Bureau want to seat at the table in the
study committee certainly okay
Kurt so again I think it's important to
say that we're looking to have a prompt
response by trained animal cruelty
officer and resources
necessary uh through protocols set out
in the state
in any any locality would be uh that
these resources would be
available but but again it's a prompt
response is important as well as the
resources absolutely and
Jerry um I would also like to uh include
not only investigation but
prosecution okay because um a lot of
times when we're talking the misdemeanor
animal cruelty it's a police prosecutor
or often the officer themselves that are
bringing the ca case to the court so um
we need to cover that as well and also
provide resources for County Prosecutors
that kind of get these dumped in their
lap when they're not
even they're further away than the
police officers are from what the laws
are and how to enforce them uh and in
addition be careful you do not create
any new definitions we don't want to
talk about a animal cruelty officer
because there is no such thing in the
state okay so
so I am going to set if I do an a when I
do the amendment on creating a study
committee I would assume that I'm going
to want someone from police training and
standards the state
troopers Sheriff's
Department someone representing local
Bureau Human
Society
and um huh the VMA BN okay yeah
veterinarians
association
yes Chiefs
Sheriff are you Crea a stud commission
or stud committee
committee so you know how you use your
usual verage to invite any
stakers I like that you're listing it
out so that will bring people to the
table so I look at your list of your
Governor commission now it should
include all of
those
believe uh the statee would like to hear
from interested stakeholders including
and just
out
okay I'm gonna have to ask you to come
up to the mic unfortunately because
you're sorry that's okayu yourself I
know everybody's ready to leave um
Elizabeth Sergeant shanin Capital group
here representing the New Hampshire
Sheriff's Association and the New
Hampshire Chiefs of police um so just in
your study committee I would probably
just mirror your current Governor's
commission since you're working on some
of these issues now I would just add
them in as as stakeholders you'll call
as resources and then the only other
thing which I'll talk to you about
offline is but there's a uh a driver
visor card we call it so the commission
on De hard of hearing many years ago
with the cooperation of State Police um
drafted a roadside card that that you
could hand to someone for resources
maybe the commission could work on
drafting something like this once once
you do your work then you could have
this for um officers once you get your
resour your people and your resources
then maybe you have something simple
then there's your resource that you've
been looking for Statewide great idea um
Rob Madam chair Beth just brought up a
good point I mean if if the study is
going to be more than just legislators
it's a it's a commission or you just
looking for a study committee and you're
looking for the entities that that
committee is going to be yes calling yes
so it is a study committee with with I
don't want to do a commission I agree no
I I I'm glad you already have a
commission yeah I just wanted to be
clear right but but I just want to see
who everyone thinks should be here um I
want to make sure all stakeholders are
here um at all the meetings um Jerry
okay um the Department of Agriculture
state
v
um
so I think that retaining this bill or
turning it into amending it turning it
into a study committee is the way to go
I think this way we can get this right
hopefully this time around and next
year pass some really good legislation
so that we can start addressing the
issue of animal cruelty with prompt
response um is everyone in
agreement okay yes perfect um Kurt I
just want to thank the chairman for
being so inclusive in having such a
great discussion this morning thank you
oh we have to do that in order to get it
right and that's why we had the
subcommittee meeting so thank you all
for attending being here happy
Valentine's Day everyone the meeting is
adjourned